good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I've
been thinking a lot about the world's
largest ball of paint which is located
in the tiny town of Alexandria Indiana
so I know it can't possibly be a
coincidence that so many of the world's
largest balls are located in the United
States like the world's largest ball of
popcorn is in Iowa the world's largest
ball of stamps is in Nebraska there are
several competing world's largest balls
of twine from Kansas to Minnesota but
it's the ball of paint that interests me
most
so back in 1977 this guy Mike Carmichael
painted a baseball with his
three-year-old son and then they kept
fainting it for like hundreds of coats
and then they started to invite
neighbors and friends over to paint the
ball eventually strangers showed up and
Mike would invite them to add layers of
paint and now 40 years later there are
more than 25,000 layers of paint on this
baseball it weighs two and a half tons
it has its own little house and every
year more than a thousand strangers show
up to add layers of paint to it which by
the way is free Mike even provides the
paint anyway I think the world's largest
ball of paint has something to tell us
about the creation of art like usually
we imagine art as a story of individual
geniuses right you know Shakespeare
Leonardo da Vinci or whomever uses like
their innate brilliance to expand the
human landscape now sometimes we
acknowledge that circumstances play a
role in the emergence of great art like
for instance for Mark Twain to become
Mark Twain he had to grow up on the
river that separated America from itself
during the war that separated America
from itself but mostly we think the work
is done not by the times but by these
heroic individuals who like push us
forward and lift us up now to be clear I
do believe in genius from Mark Twain to
Jane Austen to Toni Morrison there are
some artists who are just uncommon ly
great but I don't think genius is a
simple trait like having brown eyes I
think it's more of a continuum like
having empathy and also I think the
worship of individual genius in art and
elsewhere is ultimately misguided like
Thomas Edison didn't invent the light
bulb it was being invented all around
him by lots of people and he added
innovations to it and Isaac Newton
didn't discover gravity he pushed our
awareness of it to new places I think
lots of us and I include myself in this
by the way worried that whatever our
work is it won't matter because it won't
be remembered or because it won't rise
to the level of genius but maybe that
makes individuals too important maybe in
the end art and life are more like the
world's largest ball of paint you
carefully choose your colors and then
you add your layer as best you can and
then eventually it gets painted over it
gets painted again and again until there
is no visible remnant of your layer of
paint and really no one knows about it
except for you and maybe a few people
close to you to whom you told the story
but that doesn't mean your layer of
paint is irrelevant because it
permanently if slightly changed the
larger sphere right like the world's
largest ball of paint looks nothing like
a painted baseball and you're part of
the reason whether you made a youtube
video that only a few people saw or
wrote a short story that only a few
people read you still played a role in
shaping this many-splendored ball of
paint we're all living with so you add
your coat of paint or hopefully several
coats and hope that you've made the
world more beautiful and yes eventually
you will be painted over but you still
matter Hank thanks so much to you and
all the VidCon staff and volunteers for
an amazing weekend in Amsterdam at
VidCon Europe I'm gonna enjoy a couple
days of vacation and then get back to
painting okay I'll see you on Friday